[Music]
hello everyone how you doing is me Pete
also notice now though here to give you
a review for a Bannerman by a Paseos
interactive it is an RTS campaign type
of game for you to take you're the main
character and have him redeem his honor
the campaign was it seems to be a lot
longer than I expected it to be I only
got through the first couple of missions
and it was it was fun I hadn't played an
RTS game in a really long time
and it wasn't too bad install was about
six gigs which I expected to be a little
bit smaller because it was just you know
I'm supposed to be a teaser but I soon
it was the full game and it was pretty
good there was a couple things wasn't
too sure about when I meet clerks the
first time I think I think healer not a
DPS first class like that like Templar
or warlock or or something of those of
those you know that mindset map where
your temples on so once you're putting
those temples on you could produce these
larger attacks that ended up totally
changing the tide of the battle which
was really great and I enjoyed that they
had a protagonist of the campaign that
you can kind of connect with that you
know he is the hero he wanted to do good
he wants to help the people of his you
know his home it was really great he was
so as for the graphics they the best way
for me to describe them is they they're
kind of on the lower scale of the
spectrum right now as
and most artistic type graphical games
I'm saying you know they're vastly
better than a Warcraft 3 and I know
that's a little hard to I mean a
Starcraft 2 non regular Starcraft and
I'm not talking about you know it's hard
to compare because you know it is you
know but at the same time it was some
quality and what I really enjoyed was
the environment see the fireman looks so
lively and fresh and seems like I can go
out there and have a picnic under that
tree why not when I was playing it was
it was good now as for the gameplay like
I was saying and it's a classic RTS
build units sent him to go fight your
guys and you know your other opponents
and it was good as for the campaign the
first one first mission actually had you
going out to get your your main
character back out of the of the battle
and then the second campaign you know
you did you have you defending the town
from wolves the next mission you're
going out and go you know protecting the
town from bandits so it had this really
nice campaign feel of you know your your
your hero doing better and wanting to do
good and it was very good
now the the units are the same exact on
both sides which is kind of interesting
because you'll have that you know the
the archers will be able to kill the is
faster as the Warriors are able to kill
the archers faster you have that regular
type of synergy of of combat on
long-term battle by campaign it was
vastly harder than I expected but over
time it got easier
I also did a quick multiplayer map with
an AI bots and I thought was actually
harder than I expected
it was it was good you know I actually
put up a challenge and we actually
pushed back and forth for a little bit
and then eventually I was able to to win
as for replay value for me personally
I'm not a huge RTS guy but I definitely
love to to take a
is to see how others would end up
playing on a larger scale because you
know it is an eight player multiplayer
combat I would like to also say that I
tied so many times on my first mission
it was crazy
now I enjoy coming out this week 21st
22nd something like that of February so
thank you very much for allowing us to
review this and this game called
Bannerman and you know as for us we are
the iron Lords podcast we are on Sundays
at 1:00 Eastern Standard Time we talk
about games we talked about you know our
passions for what's going on and have
you have a little fight combat talk we
have you know some more things that are
coming up and we have some great
interviews and I think episode 100 is
coming in this month this month this
week this week and I think you guys are
gonna enjoy it so thank you very much
and hopefully I will get to see you on
Sunday
you